so one of the biggest dividing lines we
could call it between the American left
and right is about what role should
government have in our lives how big
should government be what are the things
that government should and shouldn't be
doing and the public policy mood
estimate is a measure of exactly that
and it is at the most liberal point in
the 68 year history of the measure and
it's really important to understand that
this measure doesn't address the
public's view on a lot of the issues
that have been big parts of the Donald
Trump administration so immigration is
not addressed by the public policy mood
report trade is not in any way addressed
by this it's specifically related to the
role and scope of government in society
and I have to tell you the results are
not actually very surprising because
when we look at individual issue polls
where people are asked should the
government provide a basic level of
health care to everybody regardless of
whether they can pay for it the country
is the most to the left that it has been
on that issue people by and large
thinking the answer is yes the
government should provide some basic
level of care to everybody even if they
can't pay for it and part of the reason
why is that whether you're symp
sympathies to that idea our ideological
or moral or economic we now realize that
hey we're a well rich enough country
that we can be making sure everybody has
a basic level of care and it's also good
economically because when people have
access to health care all sorts of other
negative externalities are mitigated
like work absenteeism and productivity
if that is what you care about or
criminality related to needing money to
pay for medical treatments medical
bankruptcies all of that stuff whatever
your sympathies are with regards to
health care more and more of the country
now recognizes everybody is better off
if the government does something that we
can very easily afford to do which is
make sure everybody has some basic level
of care on the issue of Taxation should
the government be using taxation to
reduce income inequality by taxing the
very very rich the country has moved to
the left on that it has been a
significant and
that he move to the left now I know that
there are still people who don't want
the rich to be taxed I know there are
still people who believe that it's not
good economically to tax the very very
rich to lift the bottom end and make
sure nobody gets left behind you can
find those people many of them voted for
Trump but in total the country has moved
to the left in terms of believing that
that is a role that government should be
playing this is why Republicans don't
want people to vote when you understand
and recognize that on the issues the
country is well to the left of our
elected officials you don't want people
to vote the ideas that people have come
around to and this is bigger than Trump
are more or less the ideas of Franklin D
Roosevelt second Bill of Rights
FDR proposed this during his 1944 State
of the Union address the canoe the
elements of it were employment a bill of
rights that contains employment meaning
the right to work food clothing and
leisure with enough income to support
those activities a farmer's right to a
fair income this was very important in
the u.s. at the time freedom from unfair
competition and monopolies Elizabeth
Warren is talking about this housing
medical care social security and
education this is from 1944 I would add
to the second Bill of Rights now
protecting the environment in the
context of the climate crisis that we're
facing but this is all about
government's role and on government's
role in total the country is as left as
it has ever been so if we fix our
election system we might actually have a
shot at making more of these things a
reality because the most liberal public
mood ever is not going to get
progressive politicians elected if we
don't fix campaign finance if we don't
fix the election systems if we don't
stop voter suppression this does also
relate by the way to my story yesterday
pointing out that Donald Trump is mostly
the result of decades of right-wing anti
intellectualism and demonization of
progressive ideas but Donald Trump's
rise to power is also partially
a result of milquetoast centrist status
quo ideas from corporate democrats for
much of that same multi decade period so
all these issues with campaign finance
and voting systems do need to be fixed
but Democrats also need to get with it
and move to the left as some Democratic
candidates for 2020 are finally starting
to do as some members of the progressive
house caucus are finally starting to do
there's plenty of blame to go around
it's not everybody is equally to blame
but when you understand that on the
issues the American public has moved to
the left it immediately becomes obvious
why Republicans have been behaving the
way they've been behaving when it comes
to who is allowed to vote what is
required to vote what are the number of
places that people are allowed to vote
and why do they want to reduce that and
they have sporadically gone public and
made it clear remember that guy I think
his name was Mike Terzi who said voter
ID will deliver Pennsylvania to Mitt
Romney they understand this okay they're
willing to play dirty and to a great
extent they have secured numerous
endless election victories as a result
of their willingness to do it do
Democrats need to stoop to the same
level well it's not stooping when you
try to get more people to vote okay
that's called the spirit of democracy
and we need to understand all of these
elements it's fantastic that the country
is moving left we just need to make it
possible for that leftward move to be
reflected in the elected officials that
we put into power and voter suppression
voter ID reducing voting hours reducing
polling places all of that is going to
make it harder for the will of the
people which is more left than ever to
actually be made a reality